chile is for chileans screamed this man
it was a small but passionate
demonstration in front of chile's
presidential palace called to protest
against what these people describe as an
invasion from undocumented immigrants
we are against those who come here
illegally without papers
what most infuriates me is that they
come to chile and they will not even
learn our national anthem
as they sang the national anthem members
of a counter march staged a flash attack
on the demonstrators
with noise bombs sticks and rocks
at least two people were injured
in the last few months thousands of
undocumented migrants the majority from
venezuela have crossed into chile
through illegal border crossings mainly
in the northern atacama desert
many sleep on the streets some beg
others steal to survive
like the united states chile is becoming
a magnet for migrants migrants who are
looking for a better life but unlike the
united states chile is a much smaller
and a less rich country and that is
creating as you can see tremendous
tension last week a small group of angry
chileans burned tents belonging to
venezuelan migrants who were living in
squalor in a plaza in the northern city
of ikike
some describe these protesters as
fascists but they call themselves
patriots
i'm just actually a citizen defending my
own country because
migration is good but not at this level
i'm not in this way you know as they
demonstrated across the street a nervous
street sweeper a migrant rushed past
chile's government says it wants to
deport all undocumented migrants but it
is doing little or nothing to stop them
from coming in
and it is not yet providing humanitarian
shelters and aid for men women and
children who have nowhere to go when
they get here
while many chileans feel compassion and
solidarity towards the migrants
demonstrations like this one while small
are a reflection of growing intolerance
towards undocumented and impoverished
migrants who see this country as their
only hope
lucian newman al jazeera santiago